long shot my father she shot my father
and killed him as a baby and that's why
she did we should do me because I'm a
spitting image of me so Benjamin where
you from I'm from Detroit Michigan and
you rather than have seven mile of
Gratiot East Side
I moved up there when I was 12 because
the very abusive mother and my best
friend is mom adopted me she was my best
friend's mom adopted me away from my
first mother what why do you eat here
she was who I said beauty she was about
torture she was ridiculous she she
psychological emotional physical abuse
sexual abuse anything she could do to
cause my day to be harder she packaged
it up for me and served it on a cold
dish it was and when my friend's mom
found out about it she was a paralegal
and she got her firm that take the case
and then fight it it took three years
and they they got her got me from them
and I went from like a literally a multi
multi-millionaire family to a
blue-collar inner-city black family in
Detroit it was like the opposite of the
Jefferson
you know what I mean it's about a lot of
perspective from both side are you doing
it there's a lot of that yin-yang with
me I have a high IQ but a learning
disability you know what I mean there's
always a freaking counterbalance or or a
caveat you know what I mean it's like so
it's made my life interesting ly
difficult but made me appreciate it when
I got because I've never had it handed
to me I've had to struggle a little
harder than the next guy and I've gotten
to where that's in the way I wanted hold
it before he formed you give any kids
well that's what gets interested I
married my best friend growing up we
knew each other since we were two years
old we didn't get married till we're in
their 20s but
we had a daughter in 99 she's 19 going
to my alma mater OSU right now five
years ago her mother was dropped leaning
off the church and on her way home
picked up some white castle's for us it
was my one day off a week and was hit
head-on by a drunk driver and killed he
was a fire chief the Columbus Fire
Department he was on duty and he was
snockered and that was
the ultimate unfair thing because I had
a really good I had it better than I
deserved
I most people are like Figgins you got a
great girl you got you got so lucky and
I appreciated it we finished each
other's sentences we we were like that I
still freaking go up to tell her a joke
anything because no one else is gonna
get it and it leaves me freaking Hollow
and it's
I've got a small it and say you know
what it's part of my path but I really
think that one was not fair because
I came home
I was a guy I worked I was breadwinner
my wife took care of the kid took care
that the house and their business
and I tried to juggle it for about a
week and realized I cannot raise a
daughter he's 15 years old
when I'm working 14 to 16 hours a day
and cleaning my community six days a
week she's gonna be a latchkey kid
completely unsupervised there's nobody
near by to help out so not only did I
lose my wife I had to give my daughter
to my animals and I lost both my girls
you're gonna leave basically and my
daughter never understood it she thinks
I abandoned her and she thinks that I
ran away to go party and get high and
say [ __ ] you
I have tried to explain to her a
thousand times in viña when you left and
your mom wasn't there I sat in my house
and it was just silent there was nothing
and it was so depressed I heart wherever
your in-laws from you an hour and a half
I was in a few familiar with Ohio Athens
County down by the river everybody was
in Columbus including my job I choked 90
minutes to two hours each way to work
every day and I freaking sunk into the
woods
positional to your job and your in-laws
were there Columbus
why didn't you sweep up because I had
recently inherited my family home that
had been started by my
great-great-grandfather built by hand
and every generation has inherited it
and added on to it and it's time gonna
last and it was important to me to keep
it and keep it going and I couldn't do
that with maintaining another property
and you know real justice we've been
established there about a year and and
things were good and
I don't know he just
the logistics of it just wouldn't work
out I had I kind of had to do it I was
the only one it would have fallen to
pieces if I didn't and and I so you know
I I pretty much and sitting here now
the last
last of my line cut off from everybody
and I came to LA Britney start because
they didn't know anybody here and I had
no ghosts and demons and I could maybe
created fresh slate and you know what
it's
apparently the blessing because I've
never felt I feel even lonelier here
I really have met a couple people I can
barely call anybody a friend here
because I used that word very seriously
that's me you know what I mean
it's lame story with the house now well
it kind of involves her around New
Year's I found this dog
she was unwanted and abused and I was on
my way to jump off the 4th Street bridge
when I came across her she distracted me
because I worked in an animal hospital I
saw a dog and stress and I took over and
kind of rescued her from not out from
under her vehicle she freaking leaped
into my arms and just she I've never
seen a dog thank somebody so much and
bond so quickly I forgot all about
jumping off the bridge focused on this
thing and said you know what it's one
thing for me to be out here it's another
thing for a chihuahua
to be out here I'm gonna get you off
these streets sooner rather than later
and Department of Mental Health came
through recently and got me a
transitional housing at the RUS Hotel
I think I'm a month or two away from my
semi-permanent home yeah that'll be like
an SRO for a year and then that leads to
my the VA is given grant my permanent
housing which can go anywhere
yeah it's I only have a 25% disability
they don't accept my hearing loss I
Drive a tank and most every 19 kilo the
taker has some hearing loss and now they
just came out with when we were in
Afghanistan 3m gave us defective
knowingly gave us defective hearing aid
hearing protection so that just adds to
it but yeah I'm fighting them again and
they might play ball with me I I just
think my best bet justice but suck it up
finished my last semester of school and
then go back to the workforce and just
make my own way like I always have so
what happened well that was just her
depression there I had three or four
suicide attempts after
my wife and daughter left I started
drinking a lot self-destructing so I
just had to leave I found a friend of
the old friend of the family two lives
nearby they're being very nice going
over there and checking on it and making
sure everything doesn't go to pot you
know you're so on yeah it's still titled
to me if it's out in the middle of
nowhere and I really don't know if I
could even get much for it out there
because it's like I said you with me
driving so far you you could do some
does employment nearby but it's just so
lovely the property taxes are cheap it's
somewhat self-sustaining it's on the
last the last death throes of an old oil
well that were drilled there years ago
which in coal country so there's less in
the mineral that kind of pays for like
it's it breaks even pretty much working
scenery throwing some sword in there
that we're looking at if I get some back
paid for from the VA from this lawsuit
but I might I might just depending on
what the VA does is my settlement
you kick it here until everything gets
settled with them and it fun they're
gonna go ahead and retire me I might
just go there and retire and just I
think my attitude is a lot healthier now
and I would set myself up listen it's a
bumper so I didn't go down like that
again you know but I'd like to return
there I loved the peace and quiet and
the nature and it's good for me and I
think with without such a horrible
situation I think I can integration and
give it to give it a good honest shot I
just like to find someone to share with
that's not fair thank you I actually and
part of the deal with getting the
housing is this is housing for
healthcare kind of with the agent triple
h initiatives that were passed two years
ago it requires mental health care
connections medical care connections
primary care doctor regular visits
linked up for them and drugging out all
counseling and and active participation
in the program so right now I am in
twice we do intensive outpatient drug
program at homeless healthcare for
substance abuse
I've great caseworker they're a great
team so words were using I I was always
opiates and marijuana but that that's
I've come on like they call it medicated
medically assisted therapy so I take
suboxone every day it's kind of a kind
of like an abusive for alcoholics he
takes the withdraws away and prevents
you from like feeling any if you did use
so it makes it futile you know I mean
it's like pointless to use and it gives
you that it gives you what you don't
have at this first and at the early
recovery you know which is
boy - best
so I can get my patterns established my
connections established my routine
established without having to worry
about cheeky you know
physically and mentally one of the
toughest substances there is the kick
it's something that's a hell of a lot
easier to wean off of so if I ever do
you want to move off of it later that's
an option all right now everybody agrees
this is the best thing and it seems to
be working
I'm giving them clean urine and that
just so stupid like that just makes me
happy like it's something I accomplished
like did and it was like
I'm attaining my goals and that some I
haven't done in five years and it makes
me feel good and I think I'm scratching
and clawing my way back to some sort of
freaking life this almost got me it the
homeless thing almost got me to where I
was just this angry muttering spiteful
anti-social
[ __ ] you this societal norms you know
non conformist and just unwilling to
participate in society on any level and
and God let a little bit of sunshine in
and I just ran with it and I think I'm
gonna be much happier if I build my life
back instead of just say it's over and
then just let it go down it spoil it
I've got a over it doesn't suicide
attempts including holding guns to my
head
I'm still here and there's no reason I
should be so I've come to accept that
it's not my time
there's a reason I'm not dead
[Music]
because I haven't
there's no there's no explanation for it
absolutely doctors are baffled my
family's back with anybody around it's
just like how the heck did you get
through that it's because there's
something on this earth that I haven't
done yet it's bigger than me I don't
know what the hell it is
some sort of entity in the universe has
tasked me with
[Music]
carrying some sort of responsibility
through this world and I think it's
possibly teaching somebody something or
possibly mentoring somebody so they
don't have to take some of the bumps and
bruises I did but who the hell knows and
I've sort of just said okay and I've
taken a an approach where I'm not
actively seeking it but keeping it a
half an eye out for those breadcrumb
trails of okay I think I get it now
long shot my father whatever she shot my
father and killed him as a baby and
that's why she did what she did with me
because I'm a spitting image of him
somebody never met their father really
because there was an infinity past I
walked like and talk like him same sense
of humor in my mom
having that guilt she just used to be
like it's here got caught
yeah but
let's put it this way it's happening in
the middle of
in the house they just built nobody
knows what happened but her and my dad
and me and but I was a year and a half
old we were the only ones there my
mother
she moved the body there was enough
confusion at the scene to wear it it
wasn't just set it was the late 70s you
know the crime solving technology wasn't
what it is now and it looked like a
suicide and they didn't want to you know
what suicides they did go with kid
gloves and they they just kind of okay
and they left it at that and years later
I just wouldn't give up on it
and I dug it my grandmother and I said
what the hell happened and she said you
know I had
yeah she said
we covered for your mother didn't want a
tragedy to turn into too
did your tire and rubber that's my
grandfather like he was president of
Goodyear at Akron blueblood old money
did he what a family a newspaper
headline story and you know it was swept
under the rug that's how things were
handled back then and when I pushed my
grandmother she finally came clean and I
pushed it and the grandmother being your
dad my mom's my mom yeah
I
it got as far as the prosecutor the the
district attorney looked at it took in a
really honest stab at a case and just
said Benjamin there's too much here say
you know how I witness accounts are
anyway and these are 40 years old and
it's just I'm not gonna win this with
the jury child it's gonna drag your
whole family through the mud anyway and
you know what she won I I'm sorry I said
I know what happened you know what
happened but we can't get a case out of
it so that's where it stands
but I'm just glad I know what's up and
like I said my mother's miserable she is
she's paying for it
holy Sh again
1:52 so yeah she's in her late 60's she
would have to solve a text except they
think she's 67 in September yeah she's
uh she's still around
I guess my daughter Layton I told my kid
she happens to be living three blocks
away from her I said please don't be
tempted to go over to that lady's house
I know you don't want to grow up without
your grandmother in your life that's not
a grandmother that's something you don't
want to play with and they didn't get it
and when I was unable to be reached out
here off the grid on Skid Row she went
to my mom and like hey where is Ben my
dad is out of communication with me I
need to know where he's at do you have
any information she told her I died of
drug abuse years ago and Lena morn to me
in cry
that's her blood man that's her
granddaughter and she made her cry and
thought nothing of it
and
got ahold of me again I said I hate to
say I tell you so dude but you're
petting a snake and you're gonna get bit
every time with Gayle in shock and she
said I can't dad I cried uncle and I
said here's an email account I don't
care what happens to me you can always
find me with this no matter what and she
feels better with that now so the new
matter we're in touch but we're mending
a lot of broken pieces of our
relationship and it's slow but it's
there and I hope to see it come all the
way back but uh
I
if if by some chance I'm able to be
redeemed at the end of my life here on
the last half of it it would be so cool
because I've never gotten a chance to do
that I've never gotten at the end to be
smiling and feeling satisfied I always
bust my ass worked to the top and then
get kicked back down to the bottom like
Sisyphus in his bra and I'd like to
I think this is gonna be my one shot to
hold it
trophy up and say I did it and I'm gonna
say I'm not gonna waste that opportunity
because they're obviously rare in my
world and I want to run with it
good for you so I'd like to say we all
haven't seen the last minute because I
have big things coming well thank you so
much for sharing it are you very well
[Music]